[Music]
there's a three minute and 20 ish second
long scene in the middle of the animated
sci-fi action thriller ghost in the
shell' that doesn't really qualify as
sci-fi action or thriller it's a
sequence of 34 gorgeous exquisitely
detailed atmospheric shots of a future
city in Japan that's modeled after Hong
Kong and I'm tempted to make an hour
long video dissecting each shot
individually but I really want to look
at what this interlude accomplishes as a
whole by itself and in the context of
the film and its themes the first thing
to note is that this montage is full of
what Scott McCloud has called aspect to
aspect transitions McCloud is the author
of an absolutely essential graphic novel
on the art and craft of comics and in it
he describes the kind of panel to panel
transitions that have become popular in
different parts of the world in American
comics for example the majority of
transitions are action to action fitting
for a goal oriented culture interested
in telling stories about goal-oriented
characters Japanese comics on the other
hand have long featured a kind of
transition that is really very rarely
seen in the West the aspect to aspect
transition in which time is virtually
abandoned for the exploration of space
these kinds of transitions evoke a mood
they activate the senses and imagination
and they have a rich tradition in
Japan's use of maze-like and often
cyclical works of art the emphasis is on
being there instead of getting there and
it's that emphasis at play in this
interlude from ghost in the shell'
though this is animation and not comics
the aspect aspect categorization is I
think pretty accurate I mean people and
things move in these frames but it's
impossible to tell if the shots are
meant to be read as temporally
sequential and I think it's pretty
obvious that that question is really
just irrelevant what director Mamoru
Oshii accomplishes here is to expand and
draw attention to the audience's
perception of space in the film and what
kind of space is it it's the space of a
chaotic multicultural future city
dominated by the intersections of
and new structures connected by roads
canals and technology humans move about
like electricity along these avenues
plugged into the body of the metropolis
the relationship between body and mind
shell and ghost is of course a central
theme of the film which tells the story
of a female cyborg police officer who
with her team hunts down a notorious
hacker only to discover that he's an
incorporeal AI who wants to merge with
her and create a new higher life-form
since most bodies in this future world
are at least partly artificial people
locate their identities in their ghosts
or their minds but with the troubling
knowledge that these also can be hacked
memory identity and humanity are all
called question all your memories about
your wife and daughter are false they're
like a dream someone's taken advantage
of you so how can a meditation on space
illuminate the problem and theme of
identity in ghost in the shell' well
maybe the first thing we should say is
that spaces like identities are
constructed though space often feels
neutral or given like we could move
anywhere within it our movements our
activities our life is always limited by
the way space is produced in most places
but especially in big cities that
production is controlled not by the
people but by gigantic moneyed interests
state governments or both and the same
is true for identity spaces and
identities are constructed and not
always by ourselves in this respect Hong
Kong was the perfect City to model for
this film it's a city layered with
histories and cultural memory believe it
or not when ghost in the shell' came out
in 1995 it was still a colony or
territory of the United Kingdom it had
two years left on a 99-year lease signed
in 1898 which was interrupted during the
Second World War by a four year
occupation by Japan that was about to be
handed back to Communist China with
which it had little relation in both
politics and economy so who were the
Hong Kong people supposed to be then
indeed how to define identity was and
a vital question in the post-colonial
world as the old empires faded but left
their centuries of subjugation and
influence in the very streets and minds
of multicultural cities like Hong Kong
and its inhabitants you don't want to
maintain the often racist identities
imposed on you by the colonizers but you
really can't go back to what you were
before either you're talking about
redefining my identity I want to
guarantee that I can still be myself
there isn't one why would you wish to
all things change your effort to remain
what you are is what limits you look
closely at the city and you can see
these dilemmas played out in space
cyberpunk has always featured these
uneasy composites of multiple cultures
these are not utopias but they don't
have to be imagined as dystopias either
the philosopher Michel Foucault called
spaces like this heterotopia
places that exists in a dynamic state of
layered and changing meanings
heterotopia x' don't succumb to those
forces that try to make everything the
same they are marginal spaces for the
voiceless to construct identities for
themselves cyberpunks great radical hope
was that the blending of man and machine
would have the same effect on personal
identity that multicultural cities like
Hong Kong would have on collective
identity it would break down the
constructs of gender and race and class
that had defined us for so long without
our say you can see that hope in the
main character of ghost in the shell'
the three-minute aspect aspect interlude
in the middle of this film by its strong
break from the rhythm of the plot forces
us to consider the parallels between
city and body network and ghost to drive
this home the rest of the film is framed
with characters set against the city
they live in
yes spaces are made by humanity but
Humanity is made by its spaces too it's
a feedback loop a cycle made virtuous or
vicious based on the choices we make
together
ghost in the shell' wants to show us
that the dynamics of ourselves and our
spaces are one in the same
[Music]
hey everybody thanks for watching and
welcome to everybody who came in from
last week's children of men video the
response was absolutely nuts so thanks
for spreading it around I wanted to say
thank you because this is actually the
tenth video that I've made since I
started to produce the nerdwriter
full-time and it's been an incredible
ten weeks and it's all because of you
guys supporting me on patreon it
wouldn't be possible without you guys I
know some of you do it to get you know
the rewards mugs and stickers but most
of you do it because you believe in this
kind of relationship between creator and
audience and I really do - there's
nothing between us there's nothing
between me and you and I think that's
really a model for the future so thank
you for supporting me on patreon I'm
about eight hundred fifty dollars a
video now I want to try to get it to
$1,000 that's the big video just to make
this financially feasible there's a more
rewards coming next week they're
probably gonna be a Google hangout with
me so if you are a patreon patron check
on the messages for that and I'll let
you know when it is thank you again
I will see you guys next Wednesday